طبعا لكل متابعي صباح العربيه يعني سعيد
جدا ان اليوم وياي نجوم مسلسل تليفزيون
الواقع دبي نورتوا لوس انجلوس
ابراهيم شلون هذا المسلسل غير حياتك والله
غير حياتنا الافضل لان حاليا لما كل مره
اسافر اشوف ابتسامه الناس يشوفوني
دايما كنت اتمنى انه اقدر اسعد الناس
الطريق اللي اسعدتهم يعني اليوم كنت في
الفطور في عرس كافيه كانت واحد اهتم بتطلع
اخر شيء عندي ابراهيم
فحبيت تدردش وياها
فرحني لاني قدرت افرحها بمجال اللي
قدمناها في في باين اللغه العربيه حلوه
كثير ولكن صعبه شعرت انه اللغه العربيه ما
كانت عائق في نجاحنا العمل والله
المسلسل حسينا نبغى نتعلم اللغه العربيه
اللغه العربيه اللغه الجميله وقالوا لنا
نحس يوم الناس يتكلمون عربي
اللغه العربيه
واحده منهم لازم
يتجوزك
دخله مخي خربت مزاجي اخذت من همي ولا هذا
ولا هذا ولا هذا شنو ردك على الناس اللي
يقولون هذا المسلسل الواقعي كان هو كلها
تمثيل كل سكري الموضوع
في الانستغرام
[موسيقى]
صحيح
يعني
انه ما شفنا حيز كبير من المسلسل
الحمد لله وابغى اسوي الدكتوره بعد شهرين
ناس اشياء
[موسيقى]
ابراهيم ابراهيم
ههه انت دائما دائما
حاولت اقعد هناك ومايا خلاص هاي احسن
دكتور
يقول ابراهيم تعال كلمه مروان
ميت عشان اكون
خارج اسمه بينهم
[تصفيق]
المشكله
[ضحك]
عافيه عليك احلى شيء لو سانجلس الارت اللي
بها الفن اللي تشوفيه على الجدران وعلى
البنايات على حبل فانتريس
الحساسيه
قاعد ترياني لا حبيبي خلينا نرجع بخير
السلام
[موسيقى]
ههه
راح اوقف الباص الشارع يلا خلينا نوقف
هناك هناك
شويه الجو حلو
[موسيقى]
يعني
اسال على مشاركه لجين عمران في هذا
المسلسل
عمران من تقريبا 10 سنين هي انسانه رائعه
واللي يحب فيها ان هي مثال اعلى لكل
الحريم اللي عندنا في الدول العربيه هي
سوت الفايد اللي احنا نريد
الناس العالم كلها كيف
همم احنا نعيش مع بعضه دائما كانت هي لايك
تحس مثل امنا يعني بصراحه فيري فرندي مثلا
تحيه من خلال هذا اللقاء يا شباب ان
يستمتع جدا بهذا اللقاء انا اكثر ينتهي
ولكن للضيق الوقت لازم بما انه دانيه هي
يوتيوبر متعلمه على الكاميرا دائما
لكل متابعين ومحبين زبايل شكرا وشكرا على
احلى انترفيو وبنشوفكم في الاستديو
[موسيقى]